hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the monday morning podcast
for monday
uh december 7th 2020 what's going on
how are you what's going on um
i am in houston texas right now it is
sunday afternoon with 138 left to go on
the indianapolis couch versus of the
[ __ ] houston oil
house houston texans houston oilers
houston oilers houston oilers number one
i've been on the road for about a week
been doing two shows a night you know
standing next to highways i was just
out in austin texas you know what's
funny i'm doing um
dallas austin and houston now dallas and
austin i would think are like you know
conservative you know
dallas is a funny conservative you know
everything's bigger here in dallas right
they go [ __ ] big with everything but
they're conservative it's weird
you know you think if you're
conservative you wouldn't go so big
you'd be like well
you know what if we lose a little bit of
money here maybe we don't need
all four doors on that truck on that
truck um
and then everything would be all like
hey man like
let's play hacky sack and celebrate joe
biden yeah in austin
and that's not the way it was
i just did um austin texas
and it was a [ __ ] free-for-all
these people were [ __ ] lunatics in a
fun way in a fun way but jesus christ
the first show i did saturday night that
is the drunkest [ __ ] crowd i've been
in for in
on in front of in forever and i don't
want to [ __ ] on the gig because i had a
great time in the gig they the people
who booked me there
they treated me like gold they got me
this box of cigars and everything
which i held off from smoking any of
them i'll bring them home and at some
point i'm going to have one but uh
i just can't do it with two shows every
night oh freckles ain't as young as he
used to be
so um don't let my uh
mid-century good looks fool you
um yeah dude like
they were [ __ ] dude it's so funny
because
people are just so sick of being cooped
up they had
this was like full grown adults drinking
like they were pledging a frat
i mean oh fumbo [ __ ]
oh no the texans just fumbled it god
damn it
ah romeo cromell i always root for that
guy he was so great for the patriots
great [ __ ] coach god damn it
look at jj watts shaking his [ __ ]
head
what are you gonna do um i like when jj
watched uh
sax a quarterback now he does that
little cup of tea
i don't know what it means i'm i'm
taking it to me let's let's let's let's
everybody weigh him what do you think
that means when he does a little cup of
tea i think it means like hey man i'm
just like chilling
me me destroying your offensive line and
tackling your quarterback and creating
mayhem
that you're watching for me it's just
like me chilling out having a little
[ __ ]
little afternoon cup of day i could
murder a cup of tea
um yeah but people are so [ __ ] sick
of uh being cooped up everybody is kind
of going [ __ ] insane i'm so psyched
this
vaccine thing is coming out and i know
there's some people i ain't taking that
i ain't putting that [ __ ] at me or
you know dude dude you know what i heard
you know what i heard
yeah what did you hear buddy what did
you hear
do whatever the [ __ ] you want to do i
don't give a [ __ ] i'll be like first and
why won't be first in line they're gonna
do first responders and uh
other people whatever more important
people first right
at some point when they get to bald
redheads i will be one of the first in
line
[Music]
i'm ready man okay if this is some sort
of conspiracy
like because there's a lot of people i
know that have figured out the
conspiracy they figured it out somehow
on their laptop
they figured it out um it's amazing they
don't have any friends in the cia but
they know exactly what the [ __ ] they're
up to
and it's incredible um somehow they
found the secret and uh the cia hasn't
[ __ ] whacked him so i don't know i
have no idea but this is going to be fun
this [ __ ] um
what do you call it the vaccine is going
to be a fun time it's going to be a fun
time
there's a way because i think there
might be a way to not get the vaccine if
you're afraid of it
is that you just keep quarantining and
then you just wait till it just sort of
burns out
and then you're just walking around you
know
like those people that never got chicken
pox they just sort of avoid people
after a certain time if you're new to
the podcast and you haven't figured out
yet that i have no [ __ ] idea what i'm
talking about then uh
you know welcome you're not going crazy
you are thinking the exact thing
i have been doing nothing out here i
have been uh
other than my shows i was the only
people i've really been interacting with
of course other than club soda kenny and
dean
and i just uh i stayed in the room i'm
practicing my french i have turned a
corner i've got a hundred almost 145
days in a row
on duolingo i got the [ __ ] app
and now i'm listening to french radio
and now i'm i've got
uh i've been watching movies the latest
one that i
watched um
was called i am jonas
which was uh was a good movie
but the thing that i liked most about
the movie aside from the fact that you
know you just watch like if
three of those movies you start picking
because there's only so many [ __ ]
words
generally speaking people use there's
like zillions of [ __ ] words
like i've noticed like uh you know which
gave me like hope that i can finally do
this
and get over the hump and become learn
another language right
but there's other things that made me
like going like i'm never gonna learn
this [ __ ] like
one of the movies i watched they had a
horse in it
so they're speaking in french and then i
have french subtitles so i can't
they they talk too fast for me right but
the french subtitles i can read a lot of
it now but like
there was a horse in one scene and at
one point it
nade and there was the french word for
that and then after that it went like
you know and there was a word for that
it's like there's no [ __ ] way i'm
gonna learn all of this [ __ ] how am i
gonna remember that
i don't what is the english word for i
don't know what the [ __ ] that is but
they got one over there right
but anyway the coolest thing about that
i am jonas movie aside from like the way
it was shot the way they told the story
was
really cool jumping around and
everything for all you homophobes out
there it is about a gay couple so i mean
i don't know if you want to watch it i'm
just giving you a heads up you know what
i mean
um but at one point
the two uh dudes go to a movie
and the end of the movie that they s
that they show is a movie that i saw
over 20 years ago with my buddy
unfortunately just passed away
and neither one of us could ever
remember the name of it was one of the
most [ __ ] up movies i ever saw in my
life
it didn't make any goddamn sense to me
but i wasn't you know
wasn't too you know i was fresh out of
the [ __ ] uh i don't know living at
home with my parents so i didn't know
anything about artsy [ __ ]
i looked up the description it was
supposed to be like beverly hills 90210
on acid and i think maybe i took it too
literal i'd love to watch it again but i
just remembered the movie ended
spoiler alert like for years i talked
about this movie go dude i saw this
[ __ ] movie
it made no goddamn sense whatsoever and
in the end
one of the characters turned into a
giant bug
and said i'm out of here and just flew
out the window and then that was the end
of the movie
and i just remember i was with wayne
previty rest his soul we both looked at
each other like what the [ __ ] did we
just watch
and then trying to figure it out and i
was like dude did they just like
not have an ending to that movie
and then they just bailed i don't i
do not understand what the [ __ ] i just
watched but like i said like i
i was at that point um i had only
watched cowboy movies
war movies gangster movies like i wasn't
too
uh i was pretty i don't know my mind was
not expect
i would love to watch it again because i
tried
to bring it up to my wife and the
movie's called nowhere
so uh i saw the movie and i called my
wife
and i'm like i finally got the name of
that movie and then i told it to her
she's like oh yeah i saw that it was a
and she liked it and there was like
a trilogy of movies that this guy made
these really trippy crazy movies so now
i'm thinking
maybe i'll go back and i'll uh
i'll watch that so um
but anyway french is coming along
because you know you know one of the
other reasons why i did this was because
somebody told me it was too late
i said you're too old you can't learn
another language so
i don't know what it is like if somebody
said you know what you can do it you
just gotta apply yourself
and you know just every day just chip
away i
that that would make me not not do it
but then for so however the [ __ ] i'm
wired if somebody
oh you gotta be kidding me god damn it i
knew that was gonna happen
i had like i'm in houston right now so i
was either going to get the [ __ ]
eagles versus the packers
or the patriots game and i'm like come
on man come on
give me the pats game and they're going
to give me the [ __ ] packers
um anyway uh but if somebody says like
yeah there's no way you could do that
[ __ ]
i'm like all right well then i'm gonna
[ __ ] learn how to do it so
i don't know i know i'm sounding crazy
people but i've literally been by myself
i've been
alone for so [ __ ] long i learned how
to whistle without using your fingers on
this trip
finally learned how to do that
it's just like i ran out of [ __ ] to do
i don't drink anymore i don't watch porn
i i got nothing i can't smoke a cigar i
got all these [ __ ]
cheese [ __ ] shows to do
you know i'm shredding my voice out here
while having so much fun
these [ __ ] texas people are so much
goddamn fun
to perform in front of because they
don't give a [ __ ]
you know jokes don't hurt them so it's
fun and i really thought but you know
something when i was in i was in a
different part of austin
i was in a different part of austin
where i was like outside
like i'll be honest with you i actually
my view of austin texas
was just like oh my god dirty white
people food trucks and ridiculous
traffic
and of course the texas longhorns
and that [ __ ] tower where that guy
shot everybody and stevie ray vaughan
and lance armstrong right to me that was
[ __ ] austin texas
uh and matthew mcconaughey all right so
there was [ __ ] like that right
but uh i never been outside
of austin and i only saw just a little
bit of it and my god was it gorgeous
it was [ __ ] gorgeous and um
something i've always liked about texas
is
all the pickup trucks out here um
obviously i love trucks and everything
like that and there's some really nice
ones out here
the amount of people like the amount of
four-door pickup trucks that are i think
i talked about this last podcast that
you see out here i swear to god you see
these things like
almost more than you see cars like we
drove by a couple of dealerships
and um they
like the whole [ __ ] lot was like
trucks
so i guess obviously it was a truck
dealership but this the sheer
volume that they had um
here's a question i have uh i don't
understand why people don't hold on to
their cars longer
like this whole thing like every three
four years you got a new got to get a
new car what the [ __ ] is wrong with your
car
the things like get like if you change
the oil and take care of it the [ __ ]
engine block is made out of steel if you
just maintain the thing
you're gonna be fine i guess people just
like they look at them like phones
because i was kind of thinking about my
car my car finally the driver's seat
just got broken in like my car is
hilarious like
the other seats like the back seat is
just pristine
like no one's ever really even been back
there you know i had a kid's seat back
there for a minute right
um other than that like nothing and then
the driver's seat is starting to finally
it's like
broken in and getting starting to get
wrinkled and [ __ ] and i was driving that
thing and i was just thinking like you
know what i'm gonna [ __ ] drive this
car
maybe for the rest of my life
um i don't know that's how i am like if
this phone that i had right here was the
last phone i ever had i'd be
ridiculously excited i know how it works
you know takes video and all that like
because i could take video of my kids on
this thing what kills me
is like when um you like when you watch
like old
youtube videos and those [ __ ]
commenters like who's this shot on a
potato
it's like no it was shot on the best
cell phone back then
so i'm wondering is like
all of these videos that i'm taking are
they they someday going to be all
pixelated and it's like i never did it
do i need to get like a [ __ ]
video camera does anybody have any
answers to these stupid questions that i
met not stupid questions the
technological questions that i am asking
at this moment
um i would appreciate it
um so dude i am such a
[ __ ] tub of [ __ ] right now i think i
put on 15 pounds since i was in new york
but you know what i'm going home and i'm
going back on the goddamn diet for real
this time rather than skipping around
the diet i'm going to the grocery store
i got one time i paid this nutritionist
right
you know to get in shape and uh i saved
all the recipes and the grocery lists
for each week
so i have them all written down on a
piece of paper this little cookbook
thing
so i'm just gonna grab that grocery list
when i get home
bring my daughter to the grocery store
and i'm buying all this stuff and then
i'm just gonna get back on it and it's
gonna take me a month
and i'll be back into like hopefully
acceptable shape
but um i wanted to go to the gym out
here i went a couple of times when i was
in um
when i was in dallas they had this where
we were staying had like
was one of those hotels where like half
the building people lived there
the other half was just idiots like me
coming through so
they um so they had a killer gym
and we would go down there in the
afternoon and there would be nobody
there but when we when we were in austin
they had another killer gym but like
half the people like weren't wearing
masks so it's just like all right
i get it if that's what you want to do i
don't want to be involved in that so i
didn't go but i continued to eat like an
[ __ ]
um you know
i had what happened was i hit the crack
pipe early
on this tour i went and i got that
unbelievable barbecue
at the pecan lodge which if you ever go
to dallas you got to go there
and you have to get the brisket it's not
that thin cut
it's like [ __ ] it's like a half an
inch thick
it's one of the best tasting cuts of
meat it's the best barbecue i have had
and then the next night we ordered it
again and it was closed and then
and then we got this [ __ ] barbecue that
oh i already talked about this i just
remember i just talked about this
um i'm watching the highlights there are
eight is did the jets lose again just
scored 28 points
and then gave up what a late touchdown
get the [ __ ] out of there was that to
end the game
ah the poor jets i don't want to see
them go owen 16.
is this week 13 already you got to be
[ __ ] kidding me
is it really
unbelievable does anything is there
anything faster than the nfl regular
season
god damn it goes by so quick wait but
there's 17 weeks now because of the bye
week
all right there's still a month left and
then the playoffs
when's hockey and basketball and all
that [ __ ] gonna start back up
you know i don't know hopefully soon
once they get the vaccine out there
you know they'll get the first 10 waves
of people and then we'll hold down the
rest of you
[Laughter]
um anyway you know somebody took a
picture i got a poster for you there was
a guy i think he might have been going
to my show
one of dean's friends took a picture let
me see if i can get this
there was a pickup truck and dude this
guy had this i don't know
it looks like it's painted on the back
of his truck
he had this [ __ ] painted on the back of
his truck hang on a second let me see if
i can find this
all these crazy pictures i took here
um oh no i didn't i didn't upload it yet
hang on hang on no not upload what do
you say i didn't
save it yet what the [ __ ] is it
all right i'll just paraphrase cause i
don't know where the hell it is
um the back of his truck it says
covet is not real stop bullshitting
yourself
[Laughter]
is that no cov coronavirus is fake
on the other side of the truck it says
stop bullshitting yourself and it is
absolutely
gorgeous stenciled uh a beautiful font
which i think he
chose that font it's in cursive i think
he did that so
you know i guess liberals would maybe
hear what he was saying if he had it in
bold and black
which is i think you're that i think
that's the [ __ ] your feelings
uh font he went more with a
gender-neutral
a like a gender-neutral bathroom sort of
um i just said the word what is it when
you we used to call it
writing and printing cursive
[ __ ] hate that word cursive
who still writes in cursive um i do
sometimes i go in and out of it you know
like i like the way i eat
in and out of being healthy and then
eating like a [ __ ] [ __ ]
um oh you got to be [ __ ] me i got to
watch the
[ __ ] shit-ass eagles get killed by
the packers this is what i got to watch
here
come on eagles give me a game today give
me a [ __ ] game
um is that tony romo
nice okay so i got i got the a team
that's one thing i've noticed about the
pats
uh this year because we haven't been
doing good we start getting the b and c
level [ __ ]
announcers and i'm just seeing answers i
don't even know we're [ __ ] announcing
in the nfl
because we went in for 20 straight years
so it's all been like jim nance and joe
buck
every week um it's kind of cool to be
listening to other people i like the
eagles right out of the back right out
of the gate
that's it don't run it out take a knee
okay don't do anything stupid carson
wentz he's gonna have a big day today
he's gonna have a big big day this is
gonna be a great game because then i'm
showing my patriots i want to see a good
game what's [ __ ] up is i have the nfl
package
and i can't figure out my goddamn
[ __ ] password i could be watching the
pats game
on my laptop right now all right but old
stupid bill
never writes down his passwords he says
he's gonna but the second he gets his
password something else distracts him
and then he just continues to plow
forward
um oh there's the eagles center where
every time you watch an eagles game they
go he's never gonna have to pay for a
beer in philadelphia
you know which i think was true but
they've said it too many times and
people live in philadelphia such
[ __ ] they're gonna probably make them
pay for one just to go against the grain
you know what i mean
just to oh nice [ __ ] move um
anyway plowing ahead here so i got i got
four more shows four more shows and then
i come home
and i go on my supermodel diet and then
i get ready for christmas
that's basically it um
i think that's where i'm at you know
what i just ate the last thing i ordered
a nice salad
which is a good thing but i also ordered
a pizza all right i don't know why the
[ __ ] i ordered pizza
in houston texas i knew it wasn't going
to be good okay i knew it wasn't going
to be good
but i was like you know i can't eat i'm
in texas i can't eat
any more red meat out here i've had like
three burgers i've had three barbecue i
can't [ __ ] do it so i was like let me
just get a margarita pizza
uh the pizza was delivered to me upside
down in the box
like they flipped the car so
i opened the box and all i see is the
underside of the pizza and it's just
stuck to the top
and uh to my credit i laughed
and i cause just immediately it's just
like if i was in new york and that
happened i would be pissed
in boston someplace will they know how
to make a pizza i would be upset
but if you're in houston i mean and you
order a pizza you deserve
that thing to be sent to you upside down
in the box
and i am talking this [ __ ] because i'm
hoping people in houston will be like
well actually you should have gone here
and they'll tell me the good spot to go
to so anyway
i pee i turned the box over
and then i open the lid and i feel it
slowly peel away and slam down to the
bottom
and uh to the credit of the people that
delivered it to me they knew it sucked
because they gave me a bunch of salt
packets wicked with it you know
it's like yeah yeah i think you might
need this
put it on the cardboard box and maybe
take a couple of bites of that
so um anyways i'm looking forward to
doing the shows tonight
and i also feel like they're going to be
a little more covered safe than [ __ ]
uh my last gigs out here
um because the show shows were at 5 and
30. so you know if things start on time
i mean the show's going to be done by 6
30 6 40 i'll have like two hours to kill
in between and we'll just i don't know
we'll see we'll see how this thing goes
i have been having so much damn fun
though on stage i got a bunch of new
jokes
um and i'm hoping uh i don't know
i'm hoping that i can uh knock out a
couple more here because
as much as i'm tired these last four
shows of my last four shows
i mean i don't have any more road dates
until i don't know i don't know when
next year or something
but um i'm calling it right now 2021 is
gonna be the [ __ ]
okay the vaccine's gonna work nobody's
gonna get sick okay
well i can't say that but like you know
what i mean
maybe some side effects here okay phil
let's let's hedge our bets
see what i just did there i just said
it's going to be great i just started to
gash you up and then what i do i
took you back down again i apologize 20
20 20 20
20 21 is gonna be great if i can save
the year
all right i'm finally gonna get past
this [ __ ] we're all gonna [ __ ] move
forward
and hopefully help each other out okay
and
uh you know hopefully you know with the
new peace loving liberals we won't start
another [ __ ] war in the middle east
i hope we don't do that i hope we're
going to uh convert to
uh you know different energy sources
wouldn't that be nice
i gotta tell you man i [ __ ] drove one
of these teslas the other day one of
those the the
the [ __ ] soccer mom suv with the with
the two motors in it jesus
christ was that thing fast
i was just sitting there going like that
tesla dude you know what he's gonna do
next he's gonna make a [ __ ]
rv i don't think you should do it it's
so goddamn fast
if you had one of those tesla motors on
both on the both the front and the back
you couldn't i actually probably
couldn't do that can you imagine like
what
imagine an rv being as fast as a [ __ ]
motorcycle
like 0-60 i mean you get yourself in
trouble
forget about what you hit i just can't
imagine all the frying pans and
everything coming flying into the back
of your head when you slam on the brakes
or going out the back window when you
took off so
um great drive over too
from uh austin to houston
you know just seeing all of this [ __ ]
you know once you get outside of the
city you know
you start seeing like all the trump
billboards and i saw this cool place
where they had a uh
a bunch of old cars and then they had
this red plane that they had
painted trump on the side of it um
there was a sign that had like a
motorcycle in it they just saw a lot of
really like
just interesting different [ __ ] out here
so i've been i've been having fun man
um so anyway let's get into the uh some
of the advertising here
oh by the way i also uh the great joe
rogan came out to one of my shows
and um and then i did uh i
i may or may not have jumped on his
podcast the next day i can't quite
remember we will see
it's called a teaser um all right my
bookie everybody
uh with the christmas holidays i was
advertising okay my bookie hey how the
[ __ ] you doing
with the christmas holidays right around
the corner my bookie has been in a
giving mood
a 250 risk-free bet on thanksgiving
boosted odds and free bets every hour on
black friday
every hour of black friday and they
continue to give away
more freebies for cyber monday for a
sports book that is supposed to be in
the business of making money
they were giving it away that's just one
of the reasons why
i've been rolling with my bookie this
season uh the fact is if you're going to
put some action on the games whether
you're
betting nfl ncaa ncaa college ball or
college hoops
whatever your preference you want to do
it with a repeat
a reputable brand like my bookie how the
[ __ ] you doing
uh make your deposit using the promo
code bird burr and they'll match you
halfway to give you a head start on your
on building your bankroll put in 200
bucks and get an extra 100
to play with joining and depositing is
simple is a simple process
and it's quick but more importantly when
it's time to get paid
it's time to get paid uh that's quick
too treat yourself
um treat yourself to some extra cash in
your pocket this holiday season by
investing in your intuition
it's not just winter season it's winning
season
so bet win and get paid with my bookie
how the [ __ ] you doing
all right what else we got here we go
look who it is it's butcher box everyone
butcher boxes carson wentz moves him
down the field
on this opening drive uh butcher box
you know when it comes to meat quality
meat matters
but there's more to it than texture and
taste
uh better for you better for the animal
better for the environment let's let's
stop short for the animal okay
it's it's you know at the end of the day
the animal gets killed all right let's
not get crazy but i mean
i guess it lives a better life before it
gets whacked i don't know what's your
favorite cut of meat oh boy
a week in texas i think i'd go with some
pork at this point
um how do you like to prepare it i like
to have my wife do it
out in the kitchen where she belongs um
i like to do the uh
you know sear it in a skillet finish it
in the oven and then bring it back out
for a little rosemary garlic buttermilk
yeah
uh not everyone has a convenient has
convenient access to high quality meat
luckily today's sponsor butcher box
believes everyone deserves high quality
humanly sourced meat humanely sourced
humanly sourced
the humans killed it uh never be without
something to cook for dinner because
there's always meat in the freezer
one less trip to the grocery store and a
better more affordable selection two
motivate your audience talk about your
experience with butcher box well they
sent me a big box of meat i cooked it
and it was delicious
what else do you want it was already
convenient before the pandemic but now
it's fantastic i don't have to worry
about that guy who says kovid's all
[ __ ]
you know stop bullshitting yourself and
he's going to walk around sneezing on
things to prove his point
um every month butcherbox ships a
curated selection of high-quality meat
right to my
my home amazon uh all meat is free of
antibiotics and added hormones each box
has 9 to 11 pounds of meat
enough for 24 individual meals or one
porn star package
uh packed fresh and shipped shipped
frozen
and vacuum sealed so it stays that way i
can customize my box
or go with one of theirs either way i
get exactly what i want it's the best
meat shipped right to my door which
means one less trip to the grocers
options like 100 grass-fed
grass-finished beef free-range organic
chicken heritage my favorite heritage
pork
wild caught alaskan salmon you don't
know what they're gonna do
and sugar slash nitrate free bacon the
wild caught the last alaskan salad i
just pictured them you know
the wrestling match has already happened
and all of a sudden they come flopping
down the runway
uh butcher box is the most affordable
and convenient way to get healthy
humanely
raised meat with butcher bucks you get
the highest quality meat around
for just six dollars a meal and even and
they even have free shipping nationwide
except alaska in hawaii bacon for life
is back
right now new members can get bacon for
life when they sign up
uh just go to butcherbox.com that's a
package of free bacon in every box for
the
life of your subscription when you go to
butcherbox.com that's [ __ ] you ever
pay for bacon again
um because i ain't like you ain't gonna
be out there buying that meat
all right helix look i know some of you
are sleeping on saggy old mattresses at
night
and you know what you deserve better
than that okay give yourself an upgrade
with
helix sleep okay if you're lucky you
spend a third of your life in bed
sleeping you know i slept 10 hours the
first night and every other night i've
only been able to
able to get like five hours sleep
everybody's unique and he
you know maybe if i had a helix mattress
in one of these hotel rooms i've been
staying in i would sleep like a baby you
know
every everyone's unique everyone's
unique everybody's special
everyone has something to say and helix
knows that
they have several that's why they've
invented the the muzzle
pillow for yet another person who isn't
a doctor
telling you what you should be doing
during a pandemic uh no sorry
they have several different mattress
models to choose from soft medium and
firm just take
some right now somebody's going like
well bill that's what you're doing no
i'm repeating what doctors are saying
you can't just say doctors yes i can i
just did
just take their quick two-minute quiz
online and they'll match you
with a mattress that's perfect to your
body and type
body type and sleep preferences everyone
i know who has a helix
helix mattress loves it and swears by
the process simple test and easy
delivery
the best part they have a 10 year
warranty and you get to try it out for
100 nights risk free they'll even pick
it up for you if you don't love it gross
but trust me you will helix is offering
200 off all mattress orders and two free
pillows
for our listeners at helixsleep.com
that's up to 200
off and two free pillows at
helixsleep.com hey here's a great way to
experiment
on whether you know i'm right or you're
right
with this whole [ __ ] mask or don't
wear a mask all you got to do is just
run it by somebody who works at a
hospital
all right run your theory by them if
they say that isn't [ __ ] right then
you're not right
okay don't listen to me all right if
they say you're right then you tell
me and i'll i'll do what you do how
about that because i was talking to a
nurse
yesterday getting a covid test and i was
talking about what some people are doing
and she was just going like i know this
they're so [ __ ] stupid
but yeah i know what you guys are going
to say some of you anyway
she's part of the conspiracy all right
turkey fry
follow-up okay now this is what i talked
about the other day i know this this
broadcast might be a little bit frazzled
all right but i have a lot of [ __ ] here
i got to talk
i had to kind of plow through some of
this stuff because i have to get to you
guys questions because lately
you guys with your questions i gotta i
gotta tip my [ __ ] cap to you i could
expose my bald freckled head to you
you guys have been crushing it you know
especially with the uh the dumb
questions
um if you work with the uh the general
public
jesus i would love to hear from somebody
who works in the medical field questions
people have
you know if i sneeze into the crook of
my arm
and then whap it on a baby does that
mean i got the antibodies all right
turkey fry follow-up
all right over thanksgiving one of these
years i always wanted to do
dude is baker mayfield in every [ __ ]
commercial out there
this [ __ ] guy he's probably making
much as much money as the rock this year
funny thing is he doesn't look like a
quarterback he looks like a little like
tv star he looks like a kind of like a
90s
one of those 30-something shows remember
the guy with the beard he does have more
of the uh
the hitler youth fade though that
somehow came back in
who's going to be the one to bring back
the hitler mustache
you know it's going to be bono from you
too right
because remember he was talking about
how charles manson took
uh helter skelter and he's like tanoy
we're going to take it back
i guess he did i don't know i i don't
even know i haven't heard anything about
it since then
um maybe bono can grow a hitler mask
mustache
and bring that back you know for all of
us who want to have that little [ __ ]
little duster on your face
what was that mustache you know was that
just like
people who couldn't grow like a full one
sort of the the original soul patch um
the upper decker jim florentine soul
patch is that what it was all right
turkey fry follow-up
hey bibi uh listen to you i listened to
your 11
19 thursday podcast about turkey fries
and wanted to share some tips with you
as my husband and i
uh used to do them for the holidays all
right for you who aren't listening you
know the turkey fry
fry you just stick it in there and like
it's done in like 20 minutes something
crazy
and it's nice and crispy on the outside
and evidently ridiculously juicy on the
inside
you know turkey's really easy to dry out
it just really seems
to be the way to go but my issue was
like
all right and then but then for the rest
of the year i got that stupid fryer what
am i gonna do with it
just stick it in the [ __ ] garage i'm
not into that i like having a nice clean
garage
anyway uh here's some answers here for
the
the turkey fry follow-up okay the bird
is freaking delicious deep fried
do you have to season it at all i
imagine you put like some sort of
anything on it i know you make fried
chicken
people put like some you know something
hot or something in the flour whatever
i don't make fried chicken either i know
these they season the batter or
something like that
anyway and it cooks very fast deep
frying
cooks three minutes per pound
versus 20 minutes per pound roasting a
bird in the oven
do not under any circumstances once
again
do not deep fry a frozen bird yeah it's
gonna blow up right
make sure your bird is thawed out
entirely
hot oil coming in contact with a frozen
bird
will make a huge explosion
what kind of a [ __ ] lunatic would
stick a frozen would try to cook
anything frozen
well i thought it was a microwave and a
deep why would i do the southern accent
it would be something like me
i dude i thought it was a [ __ ]
microwave and a
uh and a deep fryer all at the same time
like shampoo and conditioner um
make sure your bird is thought through
okay no huge explosion right next one
you can reuse the oil and fry all sorts
of stuff
other meats veggies cookies all sorts of
[ __ ]
so that's a way to get more use out of
it of all that oil yeah and get
become even fatter man i'm worried about
that
well speaking of that i remember one
time i went to that um
i went to the red river game when i was
up in dallas at the cotton they still
played it at the cotton bowl
uh the longhorns versus oklahoma
and they had the big fair right next
door and every year they fried something
different
deep fried oreos and then they had um
deep fried coca-cola like i don't even
know how you would do that i guess you
would freeze the coca-cola
and then for i don't know how to do it
but wouldn't there be an explosion i
don't know
um yeah i don't want to be i don't need
to
be deep frying [ __ ] at my age um he said
you're spot on about it being a pain in
the ass to get rid of the oil
uh you may be able to find a service in
your area that will pick up and recycle
or you can dump it in a five gallon
utility bucket with the cover
toss that in a contractor bag and put it
out with your trash
not the most legal way of disposing oil
but it gets the job done uh my husband
and i had a bunch of turkey fryers over
the years in our backyard
in boston and they were a blast it was
before we had kids so we didn't
we also didn't have to worry about
little ones getting near the fryer
uh but we were liquored up good and
managed to keep things safe
and you seem to have good common sense
so have at it and enjoy
yeah one of my buddies the way he does
it he just
he does it in his driveway like
and brushes away any leaves anything
that could possibly catch on fire
and he doesn't seem to have a problem um
all right well thank you very much for
all of those tips
uh once i do this diet and i take off
all the weight and i'm ready to put it
back on again i'll i'll try it out
all right love from kenya uh hey billy
boy
i am a big fan from kenya look at this
look at this all around the world
people listening to this [ __ ] talking um
and have been seeing people from africa
saying
how they loved the podcast and wanted to
chime in
get out of here started from the first
episode and they've been plowing through
the old podcast and i've been loving it
um
wait are you talking about you all right
hey billy i'm a fan from kenya i've been
seeing people from africa
saying how they love the podcast and
want oh saying you wanted to chime in
started with the first episode okay i
thought you said you were walking around
kenya and people are listening to my
podcast
that didn't seem right okay so i got one
fan out there i love it that's how you
build
that's how i did in america that's how
i'll do it out there someday i'll go to
the kenya funny bone
or laugh lounge whatever you call it out
there um
eminent am and am at the point nia
diagnosed you with a.d.d
you must be early on i had to check out
nfl and hockey to understand some of
your references
for your jokes being from kenya we're
more into soccer and rugby
uh those are both great games dude rugby
is [ __ ] brutal
that is brutal brutal sport also hearing
you go off on the ladies over there just
cracks me up
watched all your stand up and i really
like the hitler bit on walk your way out
would love for you to come
and do a show here the podcast helped me
work faster
it makes the hard times bearable as i am
also a computer science student
keep doing pull-ups and push-ups and
don't get fat on us
and go [ __ ] yourself yeah you were
listening to an old one my shoulders
i'm still rehabbing them and i was doing
great and i picked up my stupid suitcase
and that one in the back just acted up
just a little bit though i think i'm all
right
i'll ice it when i get back on tuesday
um all right from syria
syria i think that's one of the only
places on the planet that doesn't have
netflix last i checked north korea and
syria i believe
um hi billy plowing ahead burr
i heard in the last two podcasts from
the fans from egypt and the middle east
and wanted to add
another one to the list i'm a 25 year
old
it engineer from syria
um aleppo
aleppo i don't know currently living in
australia we had to move from syria
because of the war and during the whole
process
your podcast of always giving my days a
positive feel and a wholesome energetic
push
i got to read these to my wife you know
when she goes off on me oh yeah
well why don't you talk to the guy from
syria that now lives in australia
he seems to see me as a ray of light
um the life back home was so similar to
growing up in the west
i think but it also depends on what city
or country you were born in
i grew up in a middle class family went
to a private school and spent my time
between studying
family church and boy scouts it also
surprised me
how lots of people think that we mostly
live in tents
or there are no christians in the middle
east but i guess there are stereotypes
for every region
hope that one day you are able to visit
and see what
was once a great country to grow up in
that sucks man
well i hope they're able to rebuild i i
just really
i don't understand it man i don't i
don't [ __ ] get it
um yeah but i will tell you this my idea
of the middle east was it was
sand and uh
mosques people in like burkas and but i
just didn't
i just didn't picture any green i don't
know what i thought it was
i just yeah i just felt it looked like
the badlands of new
like new mexico or something um
and then just see those pictures and
stuff where you have like yeah you have
green trees and all of that type of [ __ ]
i
i just i thought it was all desert over
there you know
operation desert storm so you just think
it's all a desert over there i have
you know i had no idea what it looked
like um
so although i did go to i went to israel
one time
i'm trying to remember what that even
looked like i was only there for like
a day and a half i was in tel aviv i had
a great time
such a great time you know and everybody
the palestinians were cool
israelis were cool it's kind of the
usual [ __ ]
everybody's cool and then the people up
top are yelling at each other and then
those cool people end up having to kill
each other right
uh we are the world shut up bill well i
mean that's what it seems like to me
i don't understand it i don't understand
it i'm just a guy out here [ __ ] doing
[ __ ] jokes
doing [ __ ] jokes look at the eagles
they're up three to nothing
carson wentz you know he's got him down
on the packers 30 yard line
second and eight
that guy's still got the football and
can get a beer and not have to pay for
it ah
look at that look what happens then he
gets sacked carson wentz goes down
because i brought it up all right the
[ __ ] of my street
segment from latvia oh yeah there's
always one [ __ ]
on every [ __ ] street it's like a rule
there has to be
there just has to be one all right so
now we're in latvia do you guys know
where latvia is
it's right out there near uh isn't it
near lithuania
i believe i did it in estonia i did gigs
out there one time
uh hey billy ginger nuts
uh around the world just no respect
for my glowing pubes um
i'm a 29 year old from latvia and heard
you were looking for some stories
of the [ __ ] on my street from around the
world yes
this will this will also bring people
together to know that there's people
around the world
who also have inconsiderate [ __ ]
that they live next to
uh well here's one from the good old
northern europe
mine's a [ __ ] next door since um
since i live in an apartment building
okay but he's a [ __ ] nonetheless
with his devil's trinity what is devil's
trinity you asked that's exactly what i
asked
well it's the three sources of
disturbance that blast through the walls
and into my apartment
and i'm not kidding when i say this
every single day oh my god
the old loud neighbor
number one the [ __ ] has a baby
oh come on man have a [ __ ] heart huh
he says now don't get me wrong i got
nothing against babies
and would like to have one or two of my
own someday but by god
i don't know what the [ __ ]
that dude does as a parent because his
baby cries hysterically every day
sometimes up to periods of an hour or
more
yeah he might have a colically baby or
he's just not
doing a good job um he says i lived in
the apartment for over a year now and
there hasn't been a day where i haven't
heard the screeches and screams of the
poor thing
i've honestly considered calling child
services
yeah i've kind of learned my limited
limited limited experience
as a parent like uh
kids cry for like if my kid's crying
it either needs to be changed it's
hungry
um it's tired
it needs a change of position
um or i just like bounce it up i sit on
the exercise ball just bounce it up and
down
god knows i'm not exercising on it i
just sort of
get him to go back to sleep again yeah
it's weird this
there's a lot of people that have kids
that uh
they're not too good at it all right the
[ __ ] also has a wife
and from what i hear again on the
regular they're not very thrilled with
each other
when it's not the screams of the tiny
human it's the screams of the two adults
who yell at each other
at convenient times you know around 11
p.m
and obviously more often than not their
screaming disturbs the baby who then
joins their choir of misery
jesus christ dude you're painting a hell
of a picture here
number three the [ __ ] next door number
three
oh and did i mention that the [ __ ] also
has a grand
[ __ ] piano there's no way in an
apartment he has a grand piano it's not
a stand-up piano
uh so when he's not yelling either at
the baby or his wife he's banging the
piano
keyboard so hard it sounds like there's
an orchestra right in my room
to his credit he doesn't suck but always
but he always plays around 10 11 p.m
what a [ __ ] [ __ ]
why when i'm in bed trying to fall
asleep so there you go a latvian [ __ ]
thanks for all you do
and come visit latvia again we miss your
crimson
stubble uh much love and go [ __ ]
yourself
have you tried talking to him at least
about playing the piano
and if he plays the piano he's got to be
waking the baby up maybe that's why it's
crying
jesus christ dude that whole thing just
stressed me out
that whole [ __ ] thing just stressed
me out um
all right japanese food
order authentic segment oh okay
because that guy oh that guy sent me
that how to the order the authentic
mexican food i don't want to happen i i
lost it
i thought i saved it but i i maybe
andrew still has it
so this is the deal how to uh you know
everything's like americanized so i want
to talk to the actual people
of the nationality or whatever you want
to call it that make the food
and they'll tell you how to order here
so uh this is from a japanese person
hey billy bukaki that's right you should
be proud you guys came up with the
[ __ ] corn
porn corn porn i'm a long time listener
to your podcast and a big fan of your
comedy i'm an english man who's been
living in japan for the past
ten plus years um
oh okay so it's not it's an english guy
oh jesus christ
you're going to tell me how to order
authentically well you'd know better
than me
i've never been to japan um if you're
looking for japanese food to try out i
recommend some simple japanese
air quote soul food like yakisoba
stir-fried soba noodles with pork i've
never even heard of that
uh gaidon or gideon g-u-i-d-o-n
sliced beef and gravy over rice that
sounds tremendous
and taiyaki a fish-shaped donut
with the custard filling what
dude that sounds disgusting the other
two sounded great
a fish-shaped oh no no i thought it the
donut was made out of fish
and then you had custard in it i was
just like there's no way to make that
italians couldn't even make that taste
good uh
okay so it's shaped like a fish and it
has custard in the middle
you know what you piqued my interest i
got to google that
let's see t-a-i-k-a-y-a
did i spell it right
is there anything slower than hotel
internet
oh taiyaki k.i
oh you [ __ ] [ __ ] am i really gonna
have this kind of [ __ ] internet
i got this goddamn [ __ ] zoom [ __ ] i
gotta do tomorrow
ugh is the [ __ ] problem now
i give up i mean how [ __ ] maybe
because there's [ __ ] nine million
people using it in the hotel
all right i'll take your word for it
it's a goddamn i knew this was gonna
[ __ ] happen
i've had killer internet the whole
goddamn [ __ ] tour and now of course
tomorrow
when i gotta do these zoom [ __ ]
stupid interviews
ah
then what happens you call downstairs
well the internet is not part of us
here's a [ __ ] number you can call and
no human being will ever answer it
and then you could try and figure it out
you f
look at this [ __ ]
unbelievable well
if it happens every time bill at some
point it has to be believable right
at least you can anticipate it um all
right
high level question william your paper
mache globe
oh william you paper mache globe-headed
[ __ ]
what came first uh
shallow girls at surprising volume
or social media
um i don't even understand that question
i just love your insult your insult was
worth me being confused with your
question what came first
shallow girls at surprise so dumb women
talking loud or social media
oh i think well dumb people are always
loud that's what you're listening to
right now in this podcast so i think
we've always been loud and then social
media gave us a voice
um yeah but i think it's it's like
steroid like social media makes it on
steroids i would say
that'll be my guess all right dumb
question for employees banking my brain
is so [ __ ] tired i've
been seeing all this [ __ ] lately about
how you have to get sleep and all of
that type of stuff and i just haven't
been sleeping well so
i'm [ __ ] mumbling like a jackass on
this goddamn thing
um dumb question for employees banking
dear bill i know how much you hate us
banker [ __ ]
i hate the system is what i hate
you know uh the fact that you just can't
at some point
make a certain level of money and then
be like okay
i'm done it just seems like they're just
gonna
have you running the wheel until you
drop
um all right i know how much you hate us
banker [ __ ] but i still wanted to share
my top five dumb questions from working
with the public and their finances for
the last 10 years
well i bet if you were doing oh if you
have been doing it for the last 15 years
sometime around 2005
2006 people have been like wait how the
[ __ ]
am i qualified to buy this house you
would have heard that question
all right number five when referring to
your to the feature of being able to
take a picture of a check
on your phone to deposit it to your
account
if i take a picture of cash will that be
deposited to my account too
[Laughter]
that's almost not a dumb question
because the fact that you just take a
picture
on your phone i still don't get that or
trust it
uh why is ben franklin on the 100 bill
he wasn't that great of a president
okay for those who don't get that he was
never present
um he says i love the arrogance of this
one because not only were they confident
enough to think he was a president
but they didn't think he was a very good
one at that yeah that's hilarious
yeah he's not a good president you know
you know he's not a good president
they never bring him up whenever they
talk about the great presidents or even
list the presidents
all of the presidents you never hear the
guy's name all right number three
a guy called wanting to refinance his
house
hi i need to buy my house again yeah
maybe that guy was educated and he was
probably [ __ ] on you guys because he
realized
that refinancing his house he was going
back to payment one
where if he was like five years into his
mortgage people don't understand that
they go back you go back to payment
number one and you owe 30 years again
so even though the number goes down
you know your payment goes you say your
mortgage goes from 500
to 375 a month you're still losing money
and they're making more money
by refinancing your house unless
you are planning to pay it off and then
you take the lower payment
so you can put more money towards the
interest and you're going to pay it off
in the same time as when it was 500
a month then i think he could beat the
system but um
that's actually if he's being sarcastic
then that's actually a funny question
all right number two will you move my
investments out of this account if you
get
any information before the market does
oh oh jesus
i hate to say it but i i would probably
i'd fall into that category i don't
understand how stocks work either
so he says sure buddy i'll let you know
how well your money is going
is doing when i call you from prison
[Laughter]
all right number one a woman deposited
in cash at the atm and accidentally
punched in 800.
this was back in the day when you had to
type in how much cash you were deposing
depositing and then place it in an
envelope uh
she ended up spending the eight hundred
dollars and then once we caught it and
corrected her account
she came in and asking for her 800 back
i don't even understand that that's so
dumb
wow i mean she should be happy that you
that's not some sort of uh
theft because she knew that money wasn't
real
but then again don't you bankers know
that most of the money that you're
loaning out isn't real
let's say she deposited eight hundred
dollars you can loan out 100
of that plus another 800 times two can't
you
so don't you guys counterfeit sixteen
hundred dollars
and that's how we get in trouble i do
like the latest um
uh real estate bubble the the uh
the high-end apartments or whatever
luxury apartments that you're loaning
out to people with blood money from uh
different parts of the world at least
you got the money so
i'm hoping because every city seems to
be doing massive amounts of construction
and nobody i know
can really afford to do anything right
now and you're building all of this [ __ ]
that nobody can afford
so it kind of seems like something bad's
going to happen is what i'm guessing i
don't know
car rental hey mr billy worldwide
i'm a 26 year old croatian listener from
germany who works at a rental car
who works at a rent-a-car front
desk at the at the airport it sucks ass
sometimes i feel like i'm robbing people
blind but it pays my rent
and soon enough i'm gonna leave all that
[ __ ] behind me
i'm studying web and graphic design
that's fantastic
uh through these few years of working
there have
there i've been left speechless so many
times
can't even remember all of it maybe for
the better and here is some of it
by the way the last three happens a lot
all right
guy had a fuel up okay guy had a fuel up
front option on his contract
did a two-week vacation filled fuel a
few times on different gas stations
and didn't pay for it police waited for
him on the car return
when asked why he didn't pay for it he
showed them uh she showed them the fuel
option on the contract and said
they gave me free diesel
oh my god i bet the cops were [ __ ]
dying that's hilarious
another guy wanted to try an audi didn't
know the car's name so he asked me
can i give him the car with the olympic
circles on it
oh jesus that's something i would do you
know this is just making me these are so
funny but
so much of this [ __ ] is something i
would do something alone
i wouldn't say that to the guy i would
say to my wife going like
one of the you know they got the olympic
circles i don't know what the [ __ ] is
that called
uh when i asked for a credit card and a
driver's license
people answer with why or even worse
what is a credit card i mean i'm trying
to rent you a car over here
even worse what is a credit card oh
sorry i'm trying to get your car over
here people want
me to sell them plane tickets we were at
a rental car desk
one lady actually made a scene and
started yelling at me
like she was adolf's nephew herself like
it was my fault
she can't find the lefsana
office which by the way has its whole
[ __ ] terminal
just for lassanna i can never say that
lufthana and use her own eyes and read
signs
that are in her [ __ ] language
all over the place
when asked do they cross the border
when asked do they cross the border some
reply with yeah i'm driving to australia
is there anything specific i need to
know under australia
they mean austria this is what
sorry people i can't [ __ ] read today
let me do this again
when when i asked them oh you forgot to
write some words here when i asked do
they if they're gonna cross the border
some reply with yeah i'm driving to
australia
is there anything specific i need to
know
under australia they actually mean
austria
this one is usually heard from you
americans
how can a man not love you
thank you so much uh for the podcast
love your rants and hope to see you in
munich
after all this covet [ __ ] is over
congrats on the baby boy
enjoy holla the holidays and go [ __ ]
yourself oh that guy was from germany
okay
no wonder i couldn't understand some of
that [ __ ]
um oh god my pats fans are checking in
dude are you watching this [ __ ]
um all right that's the podcast
everybody uh
i got a huge guest for the thursday
afternoon just before friday monday
morning podcast this week
so be please be sure to tune in
i'm very very excited to have this
person
on and um i had so much fun being out
here in texas
and you know if i was gonna gain a bunch
of weight i can't think of better food
than texas barbecue out here i had an
absolute
i had a ball performing for all of you
guys you guys were fun as [ __ ] the women
are great
laughing at all my [ __ ] ignorance
instead of getting uptight like they
were in new york city
last summer when i had one of my worst
experiences
as a comedian just was
[ __ ] that was just i've
it was like i got an entire career worth
of groaning
in one summer um doing that stuff so any
hoop
uh that is it and if there's any anybody
from france
anybody from france why don't you write
in with some easy french
and i'll try and read it out loud and
then try and translate it
on the fly on francais
um yeah that's it all right everybody
let's go
pats i'm gonna try to figure out how i
can watch this game online
with my internet that doesn't work okay
go [ __ ] yourselves and i will check in
on you with a huge guest
this uh this thursday all right i'll see
you